yeah hello welcome to a new video I
started the 15 minute game on ICC it
took uh almost 10 minutes to get started
okay um let's go
and play as a sawian
and um
let's see what variation I should go for
let's um try to get the night off okay
it's giving this check
yeah black has multiple options here can
interpose with the Knight on the two
squares of course in Bishop D7
I like Knight CS6 here
it's the most complicated option
okay H3 this is a very slow move of
course
what usually Castle cm and uh
opens up the center quickly
okay I want to to block the center here
and maybe try to play F5
the question is um if it is um possible
even now
yeah I think it should be possible it's
uh very often an option even if white
doesn't have uh lost and lost the tempo
with H3 H3 is just a
loss of a move here it doesn't do
anything
all right
cool too
interesting yeah one point could be
Knight F6
if he takes on F5 Bishop F5 maybe Knight
takes E5
hmm
takes the queen takes E5 and the bishop
on F5 gets lost
her take on eform and you kept us with
the queen then
the C6 Pawn would hang
but maybe I can just take Knight F6 he
takes on C6 I play Bishop D7 then you
would need to go to A6 cm
hmm
there should be should be enough
compensation if I take on e4 it might
take on E5 I need to consider this
if I retake Queen H5 check but I have
with King D7
okay let's go for this I spent quite
some time time on this
piano seven
okay uh just quickly check what if I
just um
just cover cover C6
I I intended to sacrifice this Knight F6
it's no big problem to lose this Pawn I
got uh plenty of compensation
but um I could also simply um Play
Bishop D7 now
yeah why not
and then Knight F6 with a gain of tempo
yeah black has a nice center now
it's already looking uh quite promising
I think
okay Bishop B7
and then castles
okay he might try to play D4
but I can always simply play E4 and
reply
and maybe just take first and then E4
can decide on that later
yeah black has um
more than one good idea here
okay
I'm not sure if I want to take on D4 and
then play E4 to giving him the square C3
for the night I don't think
I want to do that
someone
yeah just inform immediately
if he goes to G5
okay H2 it is
all right what now taking on D4 as
mentioned gives him the CC c c three the
C3 Square
for the night so um don't want to do
that really
so maybe just um
just D5 immediately
yeah there are many attractive options
even Queen E8 is a possibility Queen E8
G6
okay but first
play the normal move
okay this is um
at least a plan
yeah you might intend to take on e4 now
I wonder if this is a good idea to maybe
go Queen B6 here
connect the Rooks that if he takes here
I can take with a knight and always
simply recapture with the Rook on f8
Queen B6 also poses a question how you
would like to
protect the form yeah okay let's speed
up a bit
it's certainly not uh not a terrible
move
I would be surprised if it would be
right okay I can now recapture with with
Tempo on C5
yeah this is looking really ugly for
white
question now should I take on F3 and
play rookie 8 immediately
yeah it must must be very good
I have a huge development Advantage all
these pieces on the queen side haven't
moved
and he's got a weakened King side with
the G3 as a nice Square for the Knight
possibly Knight E4 G3 stuff like that
so
now rookie eight just rookie8
and then Knight E4
or do I have something
even more forcing
yeah that's
simple
the certainty should be should be fine
okay I'm expecting Queen H4 now
question is um
what I should reply to that
just Knight E4
certainly not bad
yeah 94 is a good move
threatening Bishop F2
and he cannot move
much here really
it's very tied up
and there are also other possibilities
um maybe
you can also consider rookie form the
queen doesn't have many squares
can they go to G3 but it's not not the
brilliant Square
but 94
simply threatens Bishop F2
Bishop F2 and Knight G3 just winning
everything
and I don't see a reply really
or let's say a good reply
Bishop F2 you would I think yeah I need
to set the exchange now
Knight G3 otherwise would win a whole
Rook so he needs to take on F2 now
the question is um how to recapture
I think but both moves are certainly
winning but
question is what uh what's the bigger
the the quicker option
I take with the Knight he would need to
go to H2
yeah I can then give it another check on
C7 but then King G1
is simply possible
but uh another another idea if I check
with the Knight King H2
I could also just capture on on H3
yeah I can capture on H3
g th8 g takes H3 then Rook F3
and this would also threaten Rook text
F3
so Rook takes Knight takes King H2
Knight takes H3 it would threaten root
takes F3
taking on F3 Queen G1 Checkmate hmm
this is a nice line
yeah there are multiple wins here I
guess
also an option
okay attack with the Knight now
still also taking with the queen would
have would have certainly won the game
okay let's let's consider Rook takes F3
here
Rook checks F3 GTX 83 Knight H3
threatens Queen G1 checkmate
what uh what can he do about that
I also have Rook E2 threatening
this looks like a straight wind really
what what can you do can't that don't
think there's anything
um okay Queen D4 Maybe
yeah but then I have a rookie too and
also um Queen C7
yeah that's just winning come on
let's just take it
okay just quickly checking uh
if there's something um even better
no I don't think so
maybe Queen G3 he can try
but then this check always is very
irritating
to say the least
King H1
and then Knight F2
with a terrible Discovery to come
yeah this is just the mate here
but it was I was it was dead lost I was
dead lost anyway
yeah sort of a mismatch also I have
waited 10 minutes um and then got pair
to
to play with 1600 ratings so
not not too fair to him also
yeah okay
um
thanks for watching um I'll do a couple
of more if I get the opponents
seems um somewhat quiet at the moment on
the server
yeah thanks for watching and talk to you
soon